[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joined today from british columbia
by our speaker dr suzanne simard
suzanne has developed revolutionary new
techniques for discovering the way trees
even between species
are able to articulate their needs
within the forest
welcome dr suzanne smart
hello it's an honor for me to be here my
name is dr
suzanne simard i'm a professor at the
university of british columbia
and a researcher i'm here to talk to you
today about mother trees and
how i discovered their importance in
forests
and how they contribute sort of to what
i'm calling the wisdom of the forest
so before i start i just want to
acknowledge first of all that i am
giving this talk and most of my research
is on the unseated territory of a number
of first nations
here in canada i'm actually in nelson
british columbia right now on the
unseated territory of the tanaha
the tsarnaex and the okanagan nations
when i do my work
in vancouver which is where i teach
and where my university is um that is
the territories of the musquium
the slaywe tooth and the squamish first
nations
in british columbia there are almost all
of the territories
unseated territory so it's very
important for us
to acknowledge the land on which we live
i am actually a settler i come from a
settler family but
i work with first nations and their
wisdom has contributed enormously to
what i'm about to tell you today um and
also to all of our livelihoods and will
be
in our future and i think that you'll
you'll see that as i go through my talk
so i'm going to give you some context
like what drove me to do the research i
did
my own background as a child of british
columbia and i grew up here in a logging
family a horse logging family
i grew up in forests that were are
called inland rainforests
these are amazing forests they're what
you would call biodiversity hot spots in
the world
they're also hot spots for carbon
storage and they're also the source of
our clean air and our clean water
here in british columbia and it flows
all the way down through through north
america
so the value of these forests is beyond
anything we imagined even 50 years ago
now we
understand you know how crucial they are
in our global
world and the changing global world so i
grew up in these places and my research
really started from when i was a child
and it's just moved forward in trying to
understand
how they work and how we can how we we
can honor them
and their wisdom to help us to live in a
happy and healthy environment when my
family came to north america
they eked out a living and they did it
through selective harvesting
so that what that means is that they
would take out you know certain species
and certain sizes of trees
and then left the forest to regenerate
itself there was no planting back then
it was just that the the logging was
such a light touch
that the trees were able to reseed into
these small gaps created
by the harvesting and then become a
forest
it just seemed like that my grandfather
and my uncles were all part of the
forest and the
forest grew up around them and we grew
up around the forest
and so that's how i got to know it so
everything was very labor intensive and
very
very very slow and that's so important
because
as they did this work it was a very
light touch on the landscape it was very
much
you know you just take what you need and
then leave the rest
this is a photo here of my grandfather
and my uncle's on what's called
it's a log boom in what was called this
kukum chuck narrows on the shoeshop
river they were regularly crushed in
these logging
adventures and they would have to break
up these log jams with dynamite they
would lose their hands their fingers
almost all of my uncles and grandfathers
and great uncles
had missing fingers it was pretty
exciting way to grow up
and so i actually followed in my
grandfather's footsteps when i was
uh in my teens you know if girls weren't
actually
allowed to go into forestry we were um
you know we were supposed to go into
nursing or education or something
and so um it was kind of an unusual
pathway for me and i was really lucky
at the time that that ubc where where i
went to university
had just opened its doors to girls and i
was able to start out
doing forestry and this is me when i'm
in my early 20s working
for a logging company so that would have
been in the late 70s and then the early
80s
the whole logging practices had shifted
and they shifted from this
small scale horse logging family
operations to big
industrial clear cutting and so that's
how i started out my careers is
looking at big industrial clear cutting
which was so different than what
how i'd grown up and right now in
british columbia we're really
grappling with the fact that we only
have three percent of our iconic old
growth rainforest
left going back to my own neighborhood
my own where i grew up this is the shoe
shop river where my grandparents
the smart family had homesteaded but it
had become a place of clear cutting as
well
and that you can imagine the impact that
would have had
and the changes are cumulative and we're
seeing that signature on the landscape
now this is actually a picture taken
about 15 years ago
of what our landscape looks like so i
grew up in a landscape of old growth
forests
british columbia western canada is and i
would say of the west of
of the united states as well has shifted
from a landscape of old growth forests
to a landscape of clear cuts with only
small pockets of old growth forests that
are left
there are huge implications for that
we've converted these old growth forests
to plantations
and this is what these plantations look
like clear cutting means taking away all
of the trees
and then they're replanted to one or two
species
in this case douglas fir this is a
monoculture meaning one species
and then they're cultivated or weeded
and tended to get rid of all the other
or as many of the other plants as
possible to favor
these trees with the idea being that if
you get rid of the native plants
then all those resources will be
available to grow big fat trees
of course as i moved along in my career
i eventually became a researcher and one
of my jobs was to figure out how to grow
plantations
and then if there's something wrong with
them what the heck is wrong with them
and what can we do about it
and as i started working on this and at
the time in the early 90s i was working
in the
ministry of forests the government and
that was also when the mountain pine
beetles started coming through
and we started noticing that in these
plantations so this is a plantation of
lodgepole pine
in a sub boreal spruce forest where the
beetle has specifically attacked and
killed those planted lodgepole pines
and why is that the case well the
problem here is it was planted one
species
in a sea of a multi-species forest
and so it was like a had a target on its
back for the beetle it was exactly what
the beetle wanted was a simplified
forest
that had been weeded to grow bigger
faster lodgepole pines that were the
host of the beetle
and i've done many studies since then to
show that we have like about 50
different damaging agents in these kinds
of forests now that are basically
chewing their way through and as climate
is warming up
we found that it's getting worse and
worse i started to do some research on
what's going on in the soil
so there are big pathogens that were
killing forests and
a lot of those big pathogens attacked
big roots of old trees
but we were also noticing trees dying in
plantations of course
and so i went back to school to try to
figure out what had we done
to create this imbalance in the soil and
among these fungi
that would make the forest more
vulnerable and so
i was looking at a smaller subset of
fungi mycorrhizaes
and these fungi they're mutualists that
means that they help the trees grow
they don't decay them they don't infect
them or they don't cause them to decline
and so i started studying this in our
forests the first work that i
i did on looking at connections and
communications between trees is i
started with a complex system
a simpler system would be to work with
one species but i was working with two
because i was interested in
how we were manipulating these species
and i worked with three
actually i worked with douglas fir paper
birch and western red cedar
which are all native species in my
forests and
douglas fir is the one that foresters
want because it
brings top dollar paper birch is
considered a weed
and so it's actively managed against
it's actually weeded out of forest using
herbicides and
anything we can get our hands on to get
rid of that pesky plant because it's
supposedly stealing from douglas fir
resources light water and so on
and then the third species was western
red cedar which of course
is a really valuable species for lots of
reasons but into foresters it wasn't at
that time it was considered
a pesky species even though our first
nations consider it they actually call
it the tree of life
because of all of the benefits it
provides to ecosystems as well as
people but but in the forestry world at
the time it was considered a weed as
well
but i used the three species to look at
communication and connection because
they all had different roles in the
ecosystem and through many years of
studies with my students and
and others determined that throughout
our forests
throughout the world that trees depend
on these mycorrhizaes
and that these plants actually are
networked together into a single unit by
these fungi that
all of the trees all over the world with
their mycorrhizal fungi
actually are connected together we are
also able to detect
defense enzymes and how when a tree is
injured like a mother tree gets attacked
by the mountain pine beetle
what kind of messages is that tree
sending to to neighboring seedlings and
so we're able to actually detect these
enzymes that end up
in the neighboring plants and how the
the rna and the dna
is upregulated in response to those
enzymes so that these neighboring plants
can actually
upregulate and produce their own defense
enzymes as well
at the time there was a lot of
skepticism about this i published a
paper in nature that
went into what these connections meant
to the forest
and there was a lot of skepticism that
these things didn't actually exist
in nature or they weren't important
these fungi
you can't see them with the naked eye um
even the a microscope even though you
can see them on the root tips
you can't actually see how these threads
move or travel through the soil
and so eventually we got molecular tools
where we could actually you know
identify fungi based based on their dna
sequences
and we went into a forest of douglas fir
a simple forest you know it was a native
or primary forest
that means that it had never been logged
and so we went in and we wanted to map
the fungi and the trees in this map the
circles in the fred year represent trees
and the bigger the circle the bigger the
tree and the darker the circle
the older the tree so the oldest trees
in this
little forest are about 300 years old
and the youngest trees which are the
little yellow
circles in the middle are about 10 years
old
and so it's a multi-age forest based on
this figure
so we call those uneven age forests and
you can see
there's about 60 trees in this forest um
and then the lines that are linking
these different circles or these trees
together are the fungal jennas or the
individual
fungi of two species that we were
tracking
and these two sister species were
basically linking all of the trees
together
and the biggest oldest tree which is up
in the upper right hand corner of the
figure
was actually of the 60 trees was linked
to 47 other trees
and so it turned out that every tree was
linked to every other tree through a
series of hop skips and junks
and so this map alone just completely
transformed how people were viewing
forests at the time which was that
trees were individuals that that
competed for resources
and that competition isn't the only
thing that's happening in these forests
that there's a lot of collaboration
going on
in that collaboration one of the vectors
for that collaboration are these
mycorrhizal linkages
the one thing to notice is that these
little trees these little yellow
seedlings that you can see here these 10
year olds
when the seed falls from the old trees
these old big old
300 year old trees the seed falls to the
forest floor
it germinates you know as soon as it
germinates it
the seed will send a hypocotyl down into
the soil which starts sending signals
to the other roots and fungi and
critters
bacteria in the soil there's a huge
communication going on
a chemical communication basically they
just link into the network of the old
trees
they become part of this big woven quilt
those seedlings suddenly have a huge
resource available to them
they've got the resources of their
elders they have they also just by
having the mycorrhizaes they're able to
also
access all of the nutrients and water in
the soil that these big old trees are
able to access as well
you know it's like inheriting a large
bank account as soon as you're born
so the other thing that happens they get
mycorrhizal but they also start
receiving subsidies
from these old trees if they didn't have
these subsidies they would die
they wouldn't make it in the understory
of these old trees it's too shady it's
too dark
they can't photosynthesize enough on
their own and so it's a very dynamic
environment throughout the life of these
trees and archived in their
tree rings then is that history they
tell a story
of the stresses and the riches that come
along to a tree
throughout their lifetime eventually
these young seedlings
themselves grow up to become mother
trees themselves
and then they you know have tons of
resources they can send to their own
seedlings
well can these old trees do they nurture
all the
seedlings can it be a different species
it's like a
community right with all the different
people in a community like my little
town of nelson with all the different
people
you know that have all their professions
and we interact in that very fluid way
it's the same thing in the forest with
all their specialties well it turns out
that these old trees
can recognize which ones are their own
seedlings they have
kin recognition and that they're able to
adjust
where they're sending carbon based on
the identity of their kin
and so in the process of doing that they
actually favor their own genes they
favor
their kin and that carries the line
forward in a real in a forest if we were
to look at every species of fungi in
every network there would be
hundreds and the linkages would be so
dense and so numerous you wouldn't even
be able to
to see that it would be just opaque
so what do we do about this other than
protesting and chaining ourselves to
trees
yes by all means let's do that but
there's we also
need to figure out ways where we can
emulate some of these more
careful management practices based on
being on the land and listening and
trying to protect
those wonderful resources and all that
at the same time as protecting
you know biodiversity carbon storage and
all
while climate is changing and making it
harder and harder and harder to do that
so how can we help these forests so i
started a project
about five years ago to try to address
some of these things
called the mother tree project the basic
idea is taking that basic research
on tree communication and connection
and applying it in forestry practices so
that we can actually
look after the basic things that we need
in order to have a life on this planet
which it means protecting our forests
protecting the carbon stocks that are in
those forests the biodiversity that's in
them
and so we wanted to retain mother trees
in different amounts and configurations
with the idea that we knew
that they were essential to regeneration
and essential to protecting all the
other creatures in the forest
and we also wanted to look at genetic
gradients because we knew
already that the rate of climate change
is so fast the velocity
is so high that trees cannot migrate as
quickly as we need them to in order to
retain
forests on our earth to retain forested
landscape
we're going to have to help them migrate
we're going to help species
and genotypes move because we've made it
too fast for them to do it on their own
i'm going to show you some of our early
results on this we focused on one
particular forest type
douglas fir because it's got this big
broad range across british columbia
so these are undergraduate and graduate
students and they are the lifeblood of
this
of this project it's a hundred year
project i'm going to be gone
well before it even reached the forest
reaches a teenage year
and so they're going to be the ones that
are carrying this into the future well
this is the biggest experiment i've ever
designed it's probably one of the
biggest climate experiments in forests
in north america so we have actually a
total of 27 forests
that have been treated in different ways
where we retain
mother trees in different configurations
and compare them to an uncut
primary forest so a native forest
and then we've taken that native forest
and cut out different patches of trees
leaving these different mother trees in
different amounts and configurations so
the 60
means that we we cut out gaps of trees
and left 60
of the mother trees and thinned them
from below to try to boost their
vigor and then with the next one this 30
is we created larger gaps in the forest
and left patches of 30
so just smaller patches this 10 is
what's known as a seed tree method it's
a very common forest harvesting method
across europe and north america where
you leave individual trees
the problem with it is that what we have
found
across british columbia anyway is that
about a third of those trees are dead
within five years
and that's part of the reasoning behind
having these 30 and 60
patches as well to protect the mother
trees from dying
from blowing over or just dying from
stress or shock
from losing its neighbors and its family
we wanted to track the biodiversity so
we measured everything
like the lichens and the mosses the
plants the trees
the small mammals the large mammals we'd
like to look at the birds
um and and also where is all the carbon
in those ecosystems we measured
you know every stick every plant every
tree we dug our soils
down to a meter and collected soil from
all those different depths
we took them back to the lab and we
measured all the nitrogen and carbon in
those samples
and we were able to actually reconstruct
the carbon budget for our forest
so all of our 27 sites then had to be
harvested by all of our partners
which was a huge undertaking and then me
and my students went out and planted all
of our special seedlings in these
forests
and now we're going back and evaluating
how they look what the biodiversity is
so one of the things along our big
climate gradient is that we know
naturally that tree species richness or
how many trees
are there varies and sure enough that's
reflected in our data
where and this also happens worldwide
that when you have
replete climates with with very good
climatic conditions there's more tree
species
and then as it gets drier and drier um
and more harsh
you have fewer tree species and tree
species richness is
correlated with carbon but tree species
richness isn't the only thing
when we look at the full suite of
species and i'm just talking about
plants right now
all through from the top of the trees
down into the soil
this is the carbon pools in our forest
and so we have
here's our dry forest at the left-hand
side of our curve and our wettest
climatic region on the far right part of
the curve
the brown part of the figure is what's
below ground
and the green part is the carbon above
ground so
here's an amazing thing is that when
you're walking through the forest
everything that you see all the trees
the plants what's on the ground
that's only half of the carbon the other
half is hidden away from site below
ground
and that is where our really stable
carbon pools are those are
so precious to us with climate change we
can take off the above ground
and harvest it and turn it into toilet
paper but we need to make sure that that
below ground pool is really stable and
safe in the ground
so that we don't double the problem if
you just look at the raw data
what this figure here is showing is that
as you increase the number of tree
species in plantations and i'm thinking
plantations here
because keep in mind we only plant one
or two species because we're very
simplistic with our management we're
always keeping that carbon pool
low if we do that right the reason for
that is as you add more species in the
ecosystem
they start occupying different niche
spaces above ground and below ground so
above ground if you look at this
nice picture on the diagram you can see
all these different tree species with
their have
occupied different layers of the canopy
some of them are photosynthesizing in
the upper canopy some are shade tolerant
and doing it in the lower canopy
but they're occupying or they're
accessing or acquiring all those sun
rays that are coming in there
and converting them into photosynthate
and it's photosynthetic that
drives the whole below ground processes
all the nutrient cycle the carbon cycle
the water cycle and what's going on
below ground too as you add more species
of trees is they too
occupy different niches in the soil and
if you start taking species away you
start
basically truncating the ability of the
ecosystem to acquire resources and be
productive
and so by simplifying our ecosystems and
it doesn't matter if it's a forest
or a grassland or a cropland that when
we simplify to a few species we actually
lose these niches or we don't occupy
them and we lower the productivity of
our
of our plant communities so there's a
lesson here for
management okay now i'm just going to
talk about
one last little piece here and that is
what is the effect of leaving these old
mother trees
on regeneration and this is just a
subset of our regeneration data so this
is really talking about the ability
of the forest to recover right it's
resilience
this is looking at total density of up
to three years post harvesting
and you can see that you know in forests
where we're intact or where we left a
lot of the mother trees
there's a lot of regen right they're
recovering really fast
as we clear cut we get less and less and
less and less you
well that seems obvious because there's
fewer trees there but there's just fewer
seed around and
they're more at risk of dying from frost
and drought and
even if they do get established the
other thing here is that the richness of
species so that is
the number of species coming back also
is greater when we leave
more over story covers leaving these
mother trees
is not just important for density is
important for the diversity of the
species coming back
along this axis here the z-axis is our
aridity gradient or our climate gradient
and this is just showing that in a
really favorable environments where it's
wet and cool
that we get a lot of regeneration as it
gets drier which is these
orange bars in front dry hot
environments it's a lot harder
so in harsher environments either
hot and dry or cold and dry regeneration
is a lot more difficult in those
ecosystems you need
a lot more protection so i mentioned how
our species our trees
cannot keep up with the rate of climate
change the velocity of climate change
is orders of magnitude higher than what
trees can migrate at the pace that they
can migrate at
and so we have to help them we have to
move them around
and so we've done that in this project
and what we found
first of all is that these warmer
genotypes that we as we move them north
they're actually doing okay right it's
warmed up enough that that they're
surviving in these warmer climates that
we've created through climate change so
our ability to migrate stuff is actually
pretty darn good
the second thing i want you to notice is
in these other figures this is the
driest and hottest site
and this is the most northern site that
most northern side is the
northern limit of douglas fir okay
douglas fir is projected to actually
migrate all the way up to the yukon
as climate changes over the next century
it's going to move if it can
it's going to move but what this is
showing is that it's they're going to
need to have
protective trees in order for them to do
that so this is our 60
retention treatment and our 100
retention
and this is the clear cut and you can
see that the clear cuts are not
the survival and the height growth is
not as great
as it is under these retention
treatments how important is this it's
hugely important
because if you fly over the north of
british columbia all we do is clear-cut
right that is all we do if you fly over
the north of
across the boreal forest all we do is
clear-cut so we're actually setting
ourselves up for
a pretty tough time if we're going to be
migrating species
this is a very compelling argument for
changing the whole thing
and we need to change it quickly because
climate is changing
so fast we need to shift away from clear
cutting in the north
to partial retention so we can migrate
species so they have their mother trees
to look after them
to help them succeed in these colder and
drier climates and therefore we can
actually
keep forests alive on the ground and
productive and healthy
and able to sequester carbon and house
biodiversity
and my final point here is that keeping
these old trees around here
also mitigates fire risk right they're
not as fire prone as young plantations
are
those young plantations full of douglas
were in lodgepole pine
it's like you could throw a match in
them and they and they just go up
because they're so flammable
but old trees they have thick bark they
have deep roots they keep the forest
moisture by bringing water up from deep
down
and they cause the the risk of fire to
go down in a big way
and we've measured that in our project
and this
just shows and i'm you don't have to
understand this whole thing but
this is just like if you look on the
blue side over here this is one of our
sites
the wettest site and it shows that clear
cutting the risk and this is just
risk of fire is higher in our clear cuts
by about double than it is where we
retain these old trees and it's because
the old trees are less
less flammable and it's also because
there's less
slash left around after after harvesting
as well
so there's multiple benefits to having
these old mother trees
for uh storing carbon for keeping
healthy forests
for having a resilient forest in the
future so let me just go through these
concluding
remarks is that our forests are under a
lot of stress
they're stressed out from climate change
and they're stressed out from how we've
managed them over the last hundred years
and this is only going to amplify in the
future and they need our help
you know we've gotten to the point where
we can't we can't just walk away
we've got to do something to help them
migrate and be productive moving forward
and we can do that by retaining these
old tree neighborhoods
for enhancing regeneration protecting
the new seedlings coming up
housing the biodiversity and protecting
those carbon stocks
and this is going to be especially
crucial in harsher environments where
seedlings just like our babies when we
grow when they grow up in our little
human families they need our help right
um those little seedlings we're gonna
need the help of their mother trees
and so we and especially on harsher
sites where
there's there's more risks involved and
we can migrate these genotypes from from
warmer to to colder climates
as climate changes we need to do it it
can be successful
but it's going to be more successful if
we leave the old trees around
in fact we could be you know it could be
a disaster if we don't keep those old
trees around
it would be like you know creating a
like a parking lot to try to put your
kids out on it
you just don't want to do that you want
to have a nice healthy environment for
them
to be moved into and how you retain
those old trees the patterns
it's all got to be based on the land
watching the land
knowing the land seeing what's going on
seeing how it's changing
that means having people on the land and
knowing the land
it means getting out of our cities and
going out and actually being part of the
management of our forests
and finally doing experiments like what
i've done with the mother tree project
is wonderful for young people obviously
for students
they can go be part of it and feel like
their agents have changed
i can't emphasize how important that is
but also we can go look at these
experiments and we can say okay that
worked and that didn't work and that
worked before but it doesn't work now
so we can use them to calibrate
ourselves we can use them to
create models to project into the future
and validate those models
and lastly to motivate us to change
because
when we when we can see what what what's
positive and helpful
then we can we can emulate that and
build on it
so thank you very much and i hope i hope
that this presentation was
enlightening um i hope that you can see
how
my early work on plant communication
and saving old mother trees is important
not just in healthy forests but how
we can use this knowledge to help us
look after our forests in the future so
thank you so much thank you so much
that was fantastic and uh i'd love to
welcome
dr suzanne simard live onto our stream
from british columbia welcome
thank you thank you for having me and
some of you have already been putting
messages into
our live stream we're already getting
some great questions we'll also have
kevin kelly one of our founders here at
long now come in for some live questions
but i'll get us started you mentioned
how
some of these trees effectively have a
memory that's encoded
in their tree rings and i think and we
got a chance to talk a little bit about
some of the other ways that that worked
with some of the native cultures and
even the way that they harvested fish
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah so you know yeah so the memory of
trees is encoded in their
in their tree rings it's also encoded in
in their the jeans and their
in their seeds um but you know in terms
of you know just annual growth rings of
a
current life of a tree um you know
there's so much information in those
rings
and thinking thinking of some of the
oldest trees in the world the
bristlecone pines are about 5000 years
old
there are trees along the west coast
redwoods and cedars that are
a thousand or two thousand years old so
that's a lot of history that's recorded
there
and one of the interesting things on the
west coast is that um
salmon salmon which migrate from the
ocean and spawn in the in the rivers
inland um carry with them a heavy
isotope of nitrogen
called n15 and n15 you can think of it
as
bio accumulating in these in the salmon
because they're
like top of their food chain and that
n15 that heavy isotope
can serve or we've used scientists have
used it as a tracer to see where that
salmon
nitrogen ends up and so when salmon are
spawning
um in the rivers we've people have found
that some of that n15 that some of that
salmon nitrogen
ends up in the trees so how does that
happen
well um when salmon spawn in the fall
there's bears that are preying on the
carcasses as well as wolves and
eagles and ravens and they they actually
carry it into the forest
in fact a single bear has been shown to
carry 175 fish in a single day
and they'll take it to um their favorite
place
um sometimes under a big old mother tree
and with their cubs they'll eat the
flesh of this
of the salmon usually they actually they
eat the brains and the guts because
that's where the most energy is
and they'll leave the the fillets the
stuff that we like to eat
which decomposes and then the mica rises
actually
pick up that salmon nitrogen along with
the n15 that's embedded in those
proteins
and it is uh carried right into the tree
rings and becomes part of the
of the tissue of the tree rings and so
we can actually
shave off those tree rings and run them
through a mass spec
and say okay there's this much salmon
nitrogen in this year was absorbed by
this tree
and so then we can reconstruct actually
salmon populations over time
and i i would add one more thing to this
story is that the
that the first nations people um knew
this for a long long time
um and they actually helped cultivate or
nourish the forest by burying the guts
of salmon that they caught
at the base of trees or at the base of
salmonberries to
increase the productivity of the forest
they would also return the bones of the
salmon to the streams to increase the
mineral
content of the stream so it's better for
spawning of salmon
and also the last thing i would say is
they also had these ancient fishing
technologies
that really helped to increase the
salmon populations they would throw back
the big mothers for example
um so that the big you know that they
would
lay big eggs for bigger fish in the
future and they were always
very conscious and aware of the
variability in the salmon populations
because they vary up and down over the
years they're on a four year cycle
and so in the years where the salmon
populations were low they didn't take as
much
and they always threw back the big
mothers and in so doing kept the salmon
populations healthy
and that kept the forest healthy as well
and of course when colonization happened
that fishery those fishery technologies
were those ancient technologies were
were either outlawed or banned or or at
least
they weren't uh learned from anyway they
were ignored
and so then the the colonization of the
fishery actually has decimated salmon
populations
and we can see that in the tree rings as
well so it's
that's interesting wow but such a
miraculous story that we have that kind
of
that much history to understand both not
the just the plant world but the animal
world that surrounded it
um it's very cool and you know long now
has uh
bristle cone pines on our property in
eastern sierra and and
learn we've been learning with the tree
wing lab and other other researchers
um like unr about how much we do learn
out of those tree rings so it's it's
pretty amazing but i didn't know the
story about the salmon so it's yeah
that's really great
and we we have a great question from uh
sean from our facebook feed asking do
the micro razia serve only as
communication medium or
are they themselves originators of
messages too are they
are they adding information into that
stream or are they just helping the
trees alone
yeah no they're they're uh partners in
this whole
complex system as well and so like the
fungi
um you know they have needs as well to
carry out their life cycle
and one of the needs that the tree
supplies is the is photosynthetic that's
the energy
um and the fungi when they're actually
colonizing a tree in order to
you know carry out their life cycle to
get the energy that they need
they signal back and forth between with
the tree the tree roots there's this
communication that goes on that's
biochemical it's constant
and what the fungi do is they message
the tree
to soften their root roots basically um
so that they can enter into this
partnership and
the tree signals the fungi to
branch and create you know we call it
what
we call apresorium where where they will
contact the root
cell and actually have a a chemical and
physical impact on the root
that then the fungus can actually
colonize the root system
and then between fungi as well fungi
different species of fungi they
they compete they collaborate they
message each other as well
um and bit with bacteria and the other
creatures in the soil there's a
there's a whole soil food web and they
all have these ways of
connecting and communicating with each
other and they enter into sort of this
food web where they have a food web of
feeding patterns and that feeding
pattern
is where you know larger uh
soil creatures will eat smaller and
smaller ones in that process of eating
down the food chain
they cycle nutrients because they
excrete out the excess nutrients
and that's what drives the the nitrogen
cycle for example in the phosphorus
cycle and all the sites these big
biogeochemical
cycles are actually based on or
dependent on these little tiny creatures
in the soil
right oh well that's amazing and after
this question i'm going to invite in
kevin kelly um but you mentioned
in the talk that you you've designed a
100-year experiment which i
love and there's so few of such things
in the world but
i want to i'd love to get a little bit
of backstory on that like did were you
funded as a 100-year experiment or
you know do you have to kind of say it's
100-year experiment and then work on
funding of you know year over year or
um these are these are very difficult
longitudinal studies like this are very
difficult to
actually work in the world so i'd love
to hear the story behind it yeah i mean
working sorry working with long-lived
large creatures means you have to have
long-lived large
experiments and you can embed in those
sort of short-term experiments to try to
understand
the mechanisms and try to predict into
the future of what the long-term
trajectory might look like but you know
there's nothing like
real data you can have all the models in
the world but you need data to feed the
models so that they're accurate
and so these long-term large experiments
are crucial
um i i became you know quite good at it
when i was a young scientist because i
was i was studying you know forest
dynamics and young stands and we knew
that we had to have
large plots that we followed over long
periods of time and so there's a whole
infrastructure associated with doing
experiments like that
first you know finding the land to do it
on and then finding collaborators who
can work at that scale
and then of course as you mentioned
finding funders who will follow
your work for a long time and you know
honestly they don't because
um funding is usually on a short scale
right
i think the largest grant or the longest
grant i've ever had is five years and so
yes it's a constant process of finding
always finding money to
to to keep the project going
but you know it's it's like you know the
more you do
and the more scientists get engaged with
these long-term projects that are
interdisciplinary
it does attract funding as well so i've
found in this project that it's actually
gotten
you know it was we were lucky to get the
money in the first place but
every year we've been successful at
getting funding and i think that
i think that that success will continue
because the project is a success
you know we're we're publishing a lot of
articles we're finding out new things
that
are directly relatable to climate change
you know i know that the government is
directly wanting our data in real time
so they can adjust their planting
policies for example
and so you know as as we've shown that
it's useful and
um groundbreaking really um it
i i feel hopeful that we'll continue to
get funding
you know through the years but i do i
think it will always be the case that
it's going to be piecemeal year after
year we have to keep chasing the money
but
you know it's worth it right yeah
yeah i mean it's it's interesting i mean
uh very obviously with things like
climate change we have to be able to pay
attention as a
civilization over decades if not
centuries
um so um it's amazing that you're
embarking on
such an experiment which i love to see
especially since we're short-term
thinkers
generally right where we at least you
know our economic
funding cycles are very short-term and
so it's it kind of goes against the
grain for long-term studies
um but it it you know you we need to do
it we have to do it
right well i think finding the
mechanisms and governing systems that
can work in this case um you know
obviously there's things like endowments
that could kind of work
you know in you know some kind of term
but um endowing every long-term
experiment might be
a bit difficult but anyway we're going
to invite in kevin uh one of our
founders here at long now and the senior
maverick at wired welcome kevin
thank you what a great talk it opens up
all kinds of visions in my mind
one of them that i was surprised you
didn't mention that
may occur to other people was the vision
and avatar
of the of the fictional
world and how well that corresponds to
the picture you just painted
and i have so many questions
about the mycelium themselves you you
you mentioned
that um they seem to treat transport
resources that you know with the new
seedling coming in and tapping into and
benefiting from
the old elders
are the fungi actually transmitting
nutrients
along the mycelium for the benefit of
the other plants or is it their own
benefit and
the plants are sort of are they
symbiotic or what
what what that's a complicated picture
it's not just
bits that are communication but you're
saying they're actual
physical resources atomic material
moving along
is is that right yeah so you know
i know that um you know we i often get
the question of who's in control here is
it the plants or the fungi
and the answer is both right they're
they're both
have agency in this and of course i'm a
forester and a tree person and so the
first thing
i did was i looked at the trees to see
you know if i adjust
their resource how replete they are in
resources
or how rich they are or if they're fully
in
lighted or if they're in the shade and i
would change sort of like these
gradients between plants and i found
that when i did that it changed
how much of these resources were were
moving and you're right it is
it is the resources it's the main things
that trees and plants need which
i and that's what i looked at where
water you know nutrients
nitrogen carbon those are the big ones
that they need and so
and they are moving them around along
what we call source
sink gradients where you have a source
plant which is rich to a sink plant
which is poor
in those nutrients or those resources
the fungi themselves
you know they have needs too they they
um they need photosynthate or they won't
survive
because they don't have leaves they
don't have chlorophyll and so they get
that carbon that photosynthetic from the
trees and it's in their
best interest to be associated with
multiple plants and multiple trees
so that if one of them dies or a whole
species dies out of the forest
then they have other options they have
other trees that they're connected to
and so and so they are connectors right
and they do have
uh agency in how these resources are
moving around as well
and one of the ways to think about that
is um that
i mentioned that there are thousands and
thousands of species fungal species in
the world
in a single forest you can have a
hectare you can have about 100
fungal species and they have different
niches um some of them are really
thick wide um almost like
very carbon rich fungi others are very
fine and
you can barely you can't see them with a
naked eye they do different things some
of them are really
those thick ones are really good at
transporting water over long distances
the really fine ones are good at you
know exploring into new places
and getting getting resources from
hidden places and then moving them
through the network um and so yeah so
so just their different roles their
different niches means that they will
have
they have a role to play in what gets
moved around and how much gets moved
around it's not just the sore sink
gradient among the plants and the trees
but it's also
the species composition of the fungi
themselves
so so the big picture you have is that
we have this forest and trees as social
beings
and we know from animals which are very
social that
their communication can be used for
cooperation but also for competition
so is there any kind of evidence that
maybe trees
as you were saying can use the the
fungal mycelium to
transmit messages of like don't come
here stay away from me
it's not the kind of cooperative helping
each other but actually
using it as a means of competition as
well
yeah yeah actually they can um so
um i know that some of these fungal
networks have been shown to transmit
even herbicides or allelochemicals the
little chemicals are like poisons
toxic chemicals that can actually you
know
poison another plant that it's connected
to um
and then and there's been a number of
papers written on that it's not from my
lab but other people
um and then but another thing that we
have looked at is
um is that you know we were working in
the arctic and
and one of my grad students julie deslip
was looking at bachelor nana which is
a shrub species that is actually
expanding across the arctic
as the as permafrost is melting and
bachelor nana it's a shrub it's been
slowly replacing or taking over
the tussock tundra and that's because
you know there's more nutrients
available as the permafrost melts
but also these bachelor nana are clonal
and they form mycorrhizal networks with
each other
and they transmit carbon from one
parent plant to a daughter plant to
another daughter plant and so on
and this is facilitated we think the
expansion of bachelor nana
across the arctic and that's not
necessarily a good thing because
it accelerates the warming and the
melting of the permafrost
on the other hand it also means we've
got more photosynthetic capacity
in the arctic but overall you know this
is a response that to
a fairly negative anthropogenic
climate change driven climate change
that
ultimately is going to be difficult for
us all to deal with
if if people in the logging industry
and others sure absorb your message
about the
necessary social aspect of these forests
and
how it could benefit even them in the
long term are there new
technologies that would allow more
selective harvesting
or are there ways to do this other than
just making it more expensive
are you aware of ways in which
we can necessarily do this without
necessarily making wood cost five times
as much
as it does right now which is very high
because of uh
shortages um so so is so are other kind
of solutions
to um working with this knowledge that
you have
you know i think that we've undervalued
our forest immensely
and we buy wood for like almost nothing
i know it seems like a lot because we're
not used to those prices
um but if we're really playing that the
true cost of clear-cutting our forests
would would be far far more expensive
and so
i think that um you know we we need to
adjust our economic expectations from
the forest and
actually value it for more than just two
by fours we need to value it for
the water the clean water that it
provides for the air it provides us i
mean how do you put a price on that
we need to put you know value it for the
carbon that can be stored
and already you know we're seeing
through carbon offsets and cap and trade
systems are
putting prices on carbon a move towards
that to valuing
ecosystems for the ability to store
carbon so it's a movement away from
these
very cheap products like two by fours or
toilet paper
that you know we've gotten used to
valuing force based on you know these
very simplistic
notions um and so yeah we can make that
change you know we need to
change the value of it just like you
know
we need to make conscious decisions we
need to make difficult decisions to get
off fossil fuels it's been
cheap for us to get that at fossil fuels
and we could kill ourselves easily by
just extracting it and extracting it
but we need to make these difficult
decisions and say no it's too expensive
you know the the externality costs of
doing that are way too high
you know and um and so sure it's
possible
of course it's possible and and i think
that the way
you know to change the value what we
need to do is just slow down
right we're cutting the force so fast
for what right we're producing all these
products that we think that we need
um we could substitute products or we
can just
you know reuse products or be smarter
about our
you know the the products that that are
used for building
houses or you know we can just be a lot
more conservative less consumptive
and then when we do log the forest take
our time
right so that when we leave the forest
that it's regenerative
not not pushing it to the point of
collapse
which is what we're doing now we're
pushing these systems to the point of
collapse
and i don't think anybody wants that for
their children or their grandchildren or
you know to leave behind collapsed
ecosystems so yeah we've got to change
how we value
you know all these life support
you know what we call goods and services
in ecology now
um but all the life support system we
need to value it for what it is which is
allowing us to live on this planet okay
and my last question
just very briefly is taking off of
zander's
point about long-term thinking and
long-term projects are you aware of
of other hundred-year surveys
in your field and
are there best practices that
are being done in terms of like say
storing data
that you get this year to make sure that
in 100 years someone can
get hold of it or other
other methods or processes that would
encourage people to
also attempt a long-term hundred-year
project like you have
you know there are some very large
projects in in the world
um uh that that need to be
protected and funded um the face
experiments are one ex
one set of experience free error carbon
exchange experiments these are
huge and they're they're well funded
where they're actually pumping co2 into
the atmosphere
in different ecosystems around the world
including forests and then looking at
the response to those
climatic changes that they're trying to
emulate there's long-term
there's a long-term ecological research
experiments that
that have been funded by the usda forest
service
um and those experiments have been in
the ground for decades
in canada you know we we have we have
joined into some long-term experiments
there's the long-term
site productivity experiments where
they're looking at how to prepare
soils over the long term but i'm not
actually aware of an experiment like
this one
you know where we've actually started it
with
a shoestring and then built it to be you
know it's
basically covers a 900 kilometer climate
gradient
and uh and so it is unique and it's
unique in that we've collaborated with
so many different partners who are
interested we've collaborated with
you know with big major forest companies
we've
collaborated with little tiny community
forests we've collaborated with first
nations
um and and research forests and so we
have
lots of interest and we've built this
thing from the ground up
and i think that um you know and we have
like you mentioned data
so you know we do store data in the
microsoft
with microsoft and we have long-term
storage in the
ministry of forests it's it's registered
as a long-term experiment
and so but it it needs people to look
after it over time
and i know through my career which has
been a long career and i've have many
long-term experiments that data
so easily gets lost even when you're
doing the best that you can
you know suddenly that whole you know
first-year data is gone who knew where
it went
so it's really important to invest in
data storage and curation and then the
continual publication of the data
it is it's a it's a big investment but
it's well worth it because already
you know in the mother tree project even
in the five years that we've been doing
this
we've found out things that you know can
change completely change how forest
practices work uh for the better
well i wish you great success in the
next 95 years
thank you
indeed i mean i think what's you know i
think a good experience thought
experiment
always with these things is imagine if
we had this material
and it was already 95 years old instead
of just five years old like it would be
the most valuable data we had on the
planet to learn about climate change
how it was going to affect us um if not
a thousand years of this data would just
be
amazing and i know um we also had a
speaker from
uh wayne clough when he was head of the
smithsonian i didn't realize this
the smithsonian is one of the longest uh
kind of uh
natural sites uh down in panama
because of when the panama canal was
created but they've continued to do
biology down there for over a hundred
years which is very cool
um i wanted to ask uh we had a great
question from
our youtube thread um have you done it
did you
as a way of doing this um did you or
anyone else do soil isolated seedlings
as a as a control to learn about how
if they can't get to the mycelial
network how much worse or better their
lives are
in this forest yes for sure we've done
quite a few experiments like that and
um you know my graduate students over
the year years we've done it in various
forest types but we
they're very simple experiments you um
what we do is we create these chambers
um out of mesh of different sizes so the
mesh has got little tiny holes of
different
calipers different sizes that allow just
water to go through
or or maybe a fine mycelium or maybe
even a large mycelium
or a root to grow through or not nothing
can grow through
and we compare and we plant these bags
basically bags and fill them with soil
plant seedlings in them and they're
either connected to the old
trees if there's big enough pores in the
bags or they're disconnected if there's
no
you know very tiny pores that only water
molecules can grow through and then we
compare
how those seedlings regenerate and what
we found
is that when when whenever a seedling
can connect with an old mother tree
that their survival goes up
significantly as does their growth rate
and their ability to to develop roots
and mycorrhizaes is all significantly
enhanced and and in stress for us which
i emphasize so much
in the talk this is really really
important
you know if you're only getting 10
survival
without a network and then it goes up to
40 which is
roughly what we're seeing that's a big
deal right
that's a big deal for the forest so so
yeah
those experiments are not hard to do but
and they're but they're elegant
and they've provided us with huge
amounts of information
nice and i think i mean that to me the
two biggest pieces of news that i got
out of this one is that the way trees
communicate and especially interspecies
is amazing but this other
thing that you mentioned that that
actually we as humans can help
facilitate
moving uh forests to um
to better climates um as climate change
is happening
to help facilitate the regrowth in um
in clear-cut areas it's potentially
further north maybe than they would have
been
is a really important piece of
information that we can actually help
this situation
um and i wanted to ask do you know are
there any institutions or others that
are
like taking on this this task of having
of helping to recruit uh into the
changing environment that we're creating
yeah we're already in canada
actively doing that and i would guess is
happening in the us as well
so the geneticists have been working
long and hard on
you know for understanding you know the
genetic
uh or the genetic makeup of
seedlings and trees and and their local
environments
and they call those provenances so so
they match a provenance to
a planting area and in the last
10 years i would say in canada they've
been encouraging
people to plant at least 10 percent of
the species mix
with genotypes that are from warmer
providences
so they migrate they're basically slowly
adding these migrants into the local
mixes of seedlings not
a hundred percent um and that's smart to
not do that it's got to be done
slowly um and and you know
moving genotypes like that because and
the reason that we're doing that
is because you know climate velocity is
about
a thousand times faster than the natural
migration rates
and if the whole forest dies because the
you know because some insect or fire
because that was climate driven
wipes out the forest um then we need to
repopulate these and we need to make
sure they're resilient and so that
they've got the right genotypes that can
survive
and re-establish the forest and we need
to make sure that we
bring these new migrants as i said in
the talk
into hospitable environments having old
trees left behind
and fires do leave old trees behind they
do
leave these legacies and and we need to
emulate that in our own harvesting
practices so that when we
migrate seedlings into new climates
where they
you know eventually will have a foothold
that they're
they're in an environment that will
receive them and protect them
and and allow them to get through those
very vulnerable early years
nice and i was encouraged to see in some
of the video in your talk that um that
young
uh i believe either undergraduates or
graduate students at least
are working in your lab and doing i know
we've talked to many
many of the kind of more extreme
explorers it's actually very difficult
for them to get the next generation to
go live out in these extreme
environments maybe your environments are
less extreme than some of these others
but how has how has it been to recruit
uh young scientists into this field are
they enjoying it doing it
they they absolutely love it i um i have
a crew of about 20 students out there
right now
um and many many students that apply and
i can't employ everybody who wants to
come
i have people from all over the world
saying can i come and volunteer
or you know even you know seniors saying
can i send you five bucks to support the
project and
um yeah so recruiting students is never
a problem and
it gives them you know they're part of
the solution then and
and then they you know talk to their
friends and they'll do
and they think of their own experiments
as well so
you know already a group of my students
are saying let's write a paper on this
one thing that i'm interested in
so you know we're training new
scientists for the future and we're
training advocates for the forest and
and once they get in those jobs they
don't want to leave them right because
they just absolutely love it yeah
it's really it's really great it's
really wonderful
well that's great and i just want to
close um so
i'd love to know if there's ways that um
that we can help you or follow your work
what are you doing next
what's how can how can our audience help
and or
what's what's next for you well you know
i think the most
important thing is to um
support the drive to save our old
forests
and so um that
and and i think that you know and to
tell your friends that this is an
important thing
it's important for everybody it's
important for us
now it's important for our kids our you
know for generations to come
this is we're at a crisis point and and
we've pushed our ecosystems
not just you know our oceans our land
our forest
and i said to the point of collapse and
we're continuing to do that
we need to pull back save these old
forests and so if you have an
opportunity
you know to um to help save the forest
so
like maybe investing in carbon offset so
that that we can
um you know substitute
making two by fours with keeping carbon
in the ground so you can do those things
you can push your governments to make
the right decision instead of always go
for the expedient
short-term jobs thing or you know and
it's and and to be honest
the and i say the jobs thing it's not
that jobs are not important it's just
that
forestry has become so mechanized that
there are less and less
jobs even as we cut more and more trees
and this
is i to me is the wrong direction
mechanization and efficiency
is maybe good for the stock broker but
it's not good for
the ecosystems um and then of course you
can invest
directly in projects like this uh
support them because they always need
funding right
the project you know i'd love to expand
this project down into mexico where
where douglas is at southern limit but
we can't work just in canada
because that's only where our funding is
from and we only have limited funding
so you could you know invest in projects
like this that span
much bigger latitudinal gradients and
you know you can donate to projects like
this if you want
right well and hopefully even projects
that uh span great
temporal gradients so thank you for
watch thank you for working on this it's
been amazing to talk with you
uh and i can't wait to follow your work
further thank you so much thank you so
much for having me
and i'd like to thank you our audience
and members and sponsors here at long
now this has been great and we look
forward to seeing you at the next talk
be well
[Music]
you